et quand même pour la grande première de
retourner dans la rue pour poser des
questions aux gens et s'habiller comme
c'est le grand retour de hong kong soit
votre frère bien sûr il revient et on
voulait pour la première j'avais encore
à surprendre et à l'âme après cinq ans
elle est partie c'est ici qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens j'ai pas grand chose à dire
dessus
le truc que ce soit un peu dommage c'est
que les de l'évier copains c'est juste
pour un trajet passe pour une heure plus
tôt et bas sera elle en pense quoi ça ça
n'est pas un cri qu'un truc chaîne
pétards boudin sur l'a12 à agent merlet
mon pote et banias et sur le côté par
anna foot un écho à savoir un boudin sur
la skoda europ assistance à un tu payes
tu paies quand tu as besoin tapez 1
est ce que vous pensez de transports en
commun parisiens puisque bien desservi
habré serait que le niveau bus
c'est beaucoup de temps mais moi je
préfère les métros plutôt que lévis
j'aime pas du tout et votre à elle en
pense quoi
[Musique]
je sais pas fallu demander la même chose
on m'a la fashion week
voilà on était au défilé balenciaga que
tu regardes impôts de 6,8
oui voyons tout le temps tu regardes tu
chantes pas non mais si tu préfères en
bosses comment s'appelle la vieille là
j'en ai jamais non plus tard je les
prends quand les scooters je peux pas le
prendre quand je peux pas prendre le
vélo ça dépend d'une méthode ça ne
dépend du temps et ses six en or de
prendre c'est un peu compliqué il ya
toujours du monde et on arrive
transpirant au boulot à part ça c'est
pas mal et votre l on pense quoi j'ai
pas de frère mais cela vaut bien sûr la
une et l'équipe des jo de pékin express
alors on est surtout ce que bangkok
recherche rotenberg
normalement on avance sur l'équipe
numéro deux hommes enfin c'est quand
même chaud quoi mais je pensais que tu
avais laissé je pensais que j'avais
réussi à me débarrasser de mes potes
transports en commun tu me fais marrant
dans tout couple depuis deux semaines
gaza fait deux semaines que je bouffe du
ri pak huige et j'en peux plus
rendez-vous au totem au total huit
auteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]